[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce nouveau 7,8
les invités une émission dédiée à celles
et ceux qui font l'actualité dans le
département est aujourd'hui mercredi 11
janvier par le notamment à pierre bédier
le président du conseil départemental
des yvelines il présentait hier ses
voeux en compagnie de patrick devedjian
son homologue des hauts-de-seine
l'occasion pour les deux présidents des
assemblées départementales de faire un
point sur le rapprochement entre leurs
territoires parole également à monique
bourges chargée de développement des
actions associatives au sein de
l'association des paralysés de france
est des yvelines elle viendra nous
présenter nous parler d'une exposition
de la pf qui a débuté aujourd'hui à
voisins le bretonneux
c'était donc laure deuxième fois leur 2e
but en commun élus locaux et des
yvelines et des hauts-de-seine était
pour une grande partie
tous réunis hier à marnes-la-coquette
pour la cérémonie des voeux des deux
départements
une cérémonie durant laquelle pierre
bédier et patrick devedjian a dressé
leur bilan depuis un an avec notamment
la création d'une société d'économie
mixte ou la mise en commun de la gestion
des routes départementales ils ont
également appelé de leurs voeux à une
accélération du calendrier en vue d'une
fusion
après les échéances électorales
nationales écouter sur ces différentes
actualités pierre bédier le président du
conseil départemental des yvelines
monsieur bédié l'an passé c'était beau
vos premiers voeux à deux là c'est la
deuxième fois un an s'est écoulé depuis
quel bilan vous tiré de ce rapprochement
entre les deux départements à c'est
forcément un bilan positif puisque vous
êtes à nouveau là ce soir et qu'on
reproduit notre réunion commune c'est
bien parce que nous sommes satisfaits
malgré les difficultés administratives
qui n'ont pas manqué malgré le
scepticisme politique eh bien nous
considérons que nous avons fait avancer
l'intérêt de nos deux départements dans
la même direction c'est à dire dépenser
mieux dépenser moins pour un résultat
identique voire supérieurs 2017 c'est
une nouvelle année d'accélération dans
le projet de fusion est ce qu'il ya des
nouveaux domaines qui vont être
rapprochée entre les deux départements
oui les décisions ont été prises de
l'année dernière la plus importante
c'est le rapprochement du service des
routes l'eau de 2000 km de route commune
vont être géré ensemble ce qui va nous
permettre là aussi de dégager des
économies et on ne dégage pas des
économies pour le plaisir de dégager des
économies on le fait parce qu'on veut
soit stabilisée soi-même réduire la
pression fiscale
notre devise patrick devedjian et moi
même c'est faire mieux et pas faire plus
faire plus c'est d'une autre époque
c'était quand on avait toujours plus
d'argent qu'ils rentraient aujourd'hui
il faut faire mieux avec autant de
moyens voir avec une moins de moyens
au sein du conseil départemental
pourtant totalement à droite il ya
quelques voix dissonantes
il y en a qui disent inquiets de la
vitesse de ce rapprochement qui disent
que ce n'a pas été discutée avant les
élections de 2015 qui sont inquiets
aussi pour le côté rural des yvelines
qu'est ce que vous répondez à ces
inquiétudes soulevées d'abord toute
inquiétude qui appelle du débat est tout
à fait légitime et y aura ce débat bien
entendu de toute façon le rapprochement
ne peut être sanctionnés que par un vote
un vote de l'assemblée donc ça ne peut
pas être la seule décision du président
dans le débat bien entendu il y aura
ensuite ce débat n'a pas eu lieu avant
2015 mais parce qu'on n'avait pas eu
l'idée avant 2015
de même que certains me reproche
généralement les mêmes de ne pas avoir
annoncé l'augmentation d'impôts avant
2015 puisque nous avons fait une sorte
augmentations d'impôts mais dois je
rappeler dans quelle situation nous
étions en 2015
nous étions dans une situation dont le
gouvernement lui même
n'avait pas dit s'il gardait ou s'il
supprimait les départements nous sommes
allés devant les électeurs sans que le
cadre d'actions le cadre de compétences
des départements étaient définis c'est
unique dans l'histoire de toutes les
républiques en france des cinq
républiques on n'a jamais vu ça et les
départements existe depuis la première
république donc bien entendu ce débat
n'a pas eu lieu avant 2015 parce qu'il
ne pouvait pas avoir lieu avant 2015
puisque les thèmes n'était pas connue
mais il aura bien entendu mieux
une dernière question puisque 2017 et
aussi d'une année nationale vous avez
débuté votre discours en évoquant plutôt
le cadre le cadre national vous avez dit
que c'est une année attendue avec
impatience impatience pour vous aussi de
voir les choses changer
je pense qu'ils les français sont
d'accord avec moi pour qu'on tourne la
page d'un quinquennat qui a été
désastreux
l'économie française va mal la société
française va mal donc on vit une crise
globale et
une crise économique sociale mais aussi
morale et je crois qu'il est temps
effectivement que la page se tourne une
invitée il nous a rejoint désormais en
plateau monique bourges bonsoir vois ça
monique bouffe vous êtes chargé du
développement des actions associatives
au sein du comité local de l'association
des paralysés de france c'est bien votre
titre c'est un peu compliqué mais c'est
vous et vous venez ce soir nous parlait
notamment d'une exposition qui vient
tout juste de débuter à
voisins-le-bretonneux à la maison de
covile plus précisément la pf qui expose
disant d'ateliers d'arts plastiques est
ce que vous pouvez nous en dire un peu
plus sur cette exposition qu est-ce qu
on peut y voir
alors on peut y voir des peintures des
sculptures qui ont été toutes faites par
nos adhérents
donc c'est un très large éventail en
fait la sculpture il ya les sculptures
de un peu dans toutes les matières en
stéatite fait je vous dirai pas tout
parce que je croyais pas toutes les
matières peinture c'est aussi un petit
peu il ya des aquarelles et à des
peintures à l'huile vallat ya toutes
sortes de choses alors en termes
pratiques cette exposition dure jusqu'au
15 janvier c'est ça jusqu'à dimanche
soir et jusqu'à dimanche soir les hommes
vous vous disais qu'ils sont toutes
exposées il y en a à peu près une
trentaine
oui victimes et elles sont du coup toute
l'oeuvre de membres de l'association
c'est le vrai travail on va dire des
membres de l'apc de travail des mêmes
dates et f oui tout à fait on retrouve
aussi des oeuvres d'anciens membres ce
sens oui on a fait appel aux assiettes
justement parce que ça fait dix ans donc
un 10 ans il est passé beaucoup de monde
donc c'était toujours agréable de les
associer
ouais le dise on se doit ce doit
rappeler des souvenirs à peu près d un
siècle on ne voyait plus pour les
personnes qui sont exposées en ce moment
à voisins-le-bretonneux c'est une fierté
pour elle justement d'être été exposés
ça doit à partager imaginer les rendre
fiers
ça les gratifie quand même quelque part
ont baissé c'est important il ya une
volonté aussi dans cette exposition de
montrer aux gens que personne
handicapés ou valides il n'y a pas de
frontières pour l'expression artistique
peu importe où tu as fait tu te fais un
fait la revoilà les c'est accessible à
tout le monde mais qu'on soit handicapé
ou pas voilà chacun peut s'exprimer à sa
façon la cc c'est une façon de
s'exprimer en fait et pour nos adhérents
c'est quand même quelque chose très très
important parce que ça leur permet de de
s'affirmer de 2 2 mètres sur la toile
tout ce qu'ils ont envie de dire
peut-être
c'est une façon d c'est une expression
en fait on s'exprime en justement du
côté artistique du côté artistique est
ce qu'on voit les gens évoluent et les
membres de l'association les oies se
libérer et prendre confiance en eux ah
oui oui on a vu certaines personnes
arrivent et qui n'avaient jamais fait de
peinture jamais fait de sculptures et
puis au fil des ans bah ils arrivent à
faire des choses très intéressantes et
là on voit on voit ce bonheur et de
fierté d'avoir d'être arrivé c'est une
manière pour elle de s'exprimer de dire
quelque chose peut-être compliqué oui
oui tout à fait parce qu'à vous prenez
une journée d'une personne en situation
de handicap vous êtes qui tout est
chronométré vous avez auxiliaire de vie
médecin vous avez des transports a fait
écouter à l'affiché voilà bien la une
pour une fois qu'ils arrivent dans nos
ateliers ils sont devant leurs toiles ou
de valeur pierre et ils sont maîtres de
leur temps ils vont pouvoir voilà ils
sont
ils y sont ils sont libres en fait donc
il exprime tout tout tout ce qu' ils ont
peut-être un magasin un magazine et
quelque part voilà un mode d'expression
durant cette exposition il ya aussi une
installation nommée l'oeuf du jour on me
dit pas de bêtise ou est-ce que c'est
l'oeuvre du jour alors l'oeuvre des
choses c'est une crèche fiers de notre
intervenant un art thérapie la personne
qui s'occupe de l'atelier peinture et
sculpture et vous verrez si c'est des
gros ce je vous dirai pas comme elle les
a fait passer il faut le détruire
voilà à dieu il faut le voir moi j'ai vu
un premier jet tout au début qu'un
teresa fait je me disais mise à et puis
rien qu'à vous voyez ça c'est vraiment
très jolie c'est vraiment à voir
plus généralement on va parler
maintenant du calendrier peut-être de
l'association d'épargné de france des
yvelines tout au long de l'année
évidemment vous proposer plein
d'ateliers plein de rendez vous plein de
rencontres et notamment pour les jeunes
il y a un groupe jeune qui organise de
nombreuses activités ce que vous pouvez
nous en parler alors le groupe de jeunes
réunis à la salle et jade
un peu élargie parce que voilà ça va
juste à 40h quoi ils se réunissent tous
les tous les mois alors un mois sur deux
c'est une réunion et l'autre l'autre moi
c'est une sortie pour qu'ils vont tu peu
partout donc voilà c'est une façon de se
retrouver entre jeunes entre personnes
qui ont les mêmes préoccupations les
mêmes désirs
parmi les activités à venir aussi il ya
un thé dansant à la fin du mois de
février oui elle alors le 26 février
on verra tout le monde à la maison de
quartier de porchefontaine à versailles
donc sauté d'un ensemble qui est
d'adosser faire une bonne action
j'essaie de c'est peut-être des projets
ben oui toutes les excès clough et sont
destinés à pouvoir financer des projets
notamment les ateliers
parce que bon même lieu tous écoutent ça
se fait pas comme cela donc à venir
danser s'amuser faire une bonne action à
la main chez aussi c'est un peu comme en
juin tombant sur votre site internet on
peut voir aussi qu'un concert est donné
au profit de la pf ce sera courant avril
donc on a un peu plus loin dans le
calendrier mais on oublie alors
jeux de mémoire c'est le 8 a pris oui
mais voilà à guyancourt d'un à la maison
que dans une maison cartier également
très bien on peut le voir sur notre site
voilà la p3 son point fr voilà tout à
fait et donc ces données par le concert
est donné par un orchestre là comme on
appelle ça la leur quête de jussiê donc
ce soit dès qu'il faut ça bénévolement
donc notre faveur alors pour terminer
cet entretien je vais parler avec vous
peut-être un sujet un peu plus barbant
puisque 2017 est une année marquée par
des enjeux politiques importants vous
savez forcément votre association se
montrent d'ailleurs très actif sur le
sujet force de force force de
proposition vous attendez quoi vous de
l'élection présidentielle vous attendez
que que de voir ce que les candidats
vont proposer de aussi mettre vos
propositions sur la table
je pense qu'on va oui nos propositions
seront mises sur la table parce que nous
notre notre combat il est il est tout de
tous les jours on va pas arrêter parce
que c'est les élections présidentielles
je veux dire nous notre combat c'est
essentiellement l'accessibilité
l'égalité des droits je le veux dire
quelles sont les priorités justement
aujourd'hui pour pour les personnes en
situation de handicap
elle a jamais giga sont nombreuses on
peut pas faire une sélection mais s'il
ya vraiment quelques peut-être quelques
sujets quelques priorités qui sont
selon-vous urgente pour des gens qui
vivent en france aujourd'hui en 2000
c'est l'égalité des droits
c'est l'égalité des droits que sur le
droit au travail le droit à choisir son
mode de vie
son lieu d'habitation cc
c'est le droit à avoir des revenus
décents parce que là aussi
malheureusement il ya beaucoup de
personnes en situation de handicap qui
sont aussi dans des situations
financières assez étriqués donc voilà ça
c'est un combat de tous les jours et
puis le droit au travail comme tout le
monde se sait pas c'est pas gagné encore
c'est très difficile quand on est
handicapé de trouver un travail
donc voilà c'est c'est l'égalité c'est
l'égalité sur tous les plans très bien
merci monique bourges d'être venu en
plateau pour plus d'informations on peut
seraient dirigés sur votre site internet
www.fff.fr c'est la fin du set 8 les
invités pour ce soir prochain rendez
vous demain jeudi 12 janvier excellente
soirée à tous sur tv fil 78
[Musique]